hey let's go impressed - okay you know
why
well can you press f2 it
it's a game about pressing f to win I
don't know anything about it let's quit
it press f to win I'm doing it
I win yes what if I don't
okay okay okay now press ever turn turn
for [ __ ] sake
press F to talk [ __ ] you I'm not gonna
press [ __ ] Oh God press F to jump
Boulder game over
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you god damn is pissing
me off
alright let's find the right I have to
click I guess guessed right are Nilla
cocaine I mean gate alright we go tag
that [ __ ] maybe I supposed to run away
from J and let that sit here we go just
go back Howard [ __ ] you not fine fine I
am look jacksepticeye don't a [ __ ]
happened there yeah I'm free to claim
this here oh [ __ ] this is gonna be hard
not to press f I didn't have to press F
[ __ ] yes okay what do I do now
okay I guess I'll go back what a [ __ ] am
i doing
welcome back here oh thank you oh okay I
am Super Mario now awesome adventurer
welcome to making them what people have
forgotten they know not over what once
was here not many stop to look and
explore the wonderful world around them
young adventurer I have one simple
question to ask a bean i am lord snail
frank that is my name but as people have
forgotten they also forgot my real name
or adventure if only you could tell me
my real name no not as a hero as a
friend please young adventurers seek my
name signature goodbye young adventurer
pray we meet again soon press F for
friendship but Frank if I press F then
the game will be over
Frank Frank I love you please don't make
me do this I'll hug you there must be
another way Frank
ah
10 out of 10 the best game I have ever
played in my entire life
the next game is a game that I've been
wanting to play for literally years
it's is one of those games where I feel
you know as I'm Swedish as you may know
and they made Sweden's simulator 2015 I
have about one and a half month left to
play this you can't play it with oculus
rift but I'm gonna play it without four
because I'm a Swedish I don't need the
full immersion experience alright and
here we are in Stockholm looking out
over the beautiful city so I never lived
in Stockholm all my friends and family
lived there now because everyone seems
to wanna move to [ __ ] Stockholm now
let's go for some serious trolling this
is how cities trawling this is exactly
how Stockholm looks like I'm not even
kidding
and everyone is blonde and there's no
diversity whatsoever I realized like
there's really no diversity in Sweden
it's it's say what you want about it
nice shoes though nice shoes Lisa hey
called Collier on far we can sleek today
I banked Bank final about quartum we're
gonna have a I'm out waiting in line
okay so in Sweden the government is
controlling the alcohol I know it's
outraged but we're just brainwashed so
it's alright but the Swedes we're very
good at standing in line we're very good
good at that's like we're probably the
best line the best comfort this country
in the world to stand in line yes
alright next one it's Vaska now this is
a little harder to explain all right I'm
gonna try my best so I used to work at a
nightclub part-time
it was fun I really enjoyed it people
it's not everyone in Sweden obviously
not everyone is a jackass but there is a
culture around spraying champagne at
each other to show that you have a lot
of money at the club all right so bag
just got out of control at the clubs so
they banned people from spraying
champagne so what instead they
implemented was Vaska which is basically
you order two champagnes and then you
drink one and the other one you order
for the bartender which is me in this
instance two busts cap which means just
pour out the champagne in the sink so
I'm not pouring it out in the sink so
this is not really a hundred percent
immersion experience that guy's pants
look like he is wearing his mother's
skin oh this game is amazing I love it
infinite champagne as well that's that's
always a plus so don't judge Sweden for
busking it's only a few idiots who
inherited their daddy's mud money and
wants to show off midsummer I like how
all of these three are alcohol-related
midsummer is like Christmas for the
Swedes it's kind of like the start of
the summer and we take our summer very
seriously because Sweden is just a
[ __ ] during winter you don't want to
be there so once the summer comes it's
actually nice and we love it so what we
do as an old tradition is to dance
around this pole here and you may think
it looks like a penis you may think it
looks like you know the inside of a
woman and the last one is correct we are
celebrating fertility by dancing around
it now technically well we would be
singing like I'm a tour guide here it's
awesome well we'd be singing this small
group tonight let's take out at sea Oh
say it with me yay or nay on days are
hardy AR on a honest and Hardy
go get got go I gotta go I gotta go I
gotta go I gotta go I gotta go
hahaha that's it that's the winter no
that's it the winters are just dark like
it gets dark at 3 p.m. and if you work
it will be dark once you go to work and
it will be dark ones to get home to work
it's just dark all the time in winter I
hope now that you watch this video that
you feel a little bit more immersed in
the Swedish universe that's it for this
video though thank you for watching
leave a like and the thumbs up and if
you enjoy Sweden and this one has Justin
Bieber's dad